kamala harris just can't get not kamala
harris on saturday night
but she can't the vice president just
can't catch a break in her attempt for a
political comeback after a series of
brutal stories that her office was a
terrible place to work yet examples of
her incompetence keep breaking example
the white house being forced to defend
harris's role as the so-called border
czar after guatemala's president claimed
last week that he had had no contact
with the vice president since last june
when she made that awkward visit to the
guatemalan capital
why is it that she has not spoken to the
president of guatemala since june that's
six months
well i know that i i did see this kind
of strange report
from the president of guatemala saying
that he's had no contact with the white
house which is inaccurate
he said uh vice president harris is not
spoken to her and if she's in charge
why why is that
if it's not her fault whose fault is it
negan
it is her fault
of course it's her fault it's her job
she accepted it now she's
trying to charge a
electric car that was a disaster she's
like one of the most inauthentic people
in washington and that's saying
something
um i think that the
i i want to talk i just quickly
mentioned that her staffers leaving i
think for me that was the biggest tell
because you're willing to be miserable
working for somebody if you think that
the road leads to the top job but they
did a risk reward calculation and they
cut bait because they saw that she was
never going to go anywhere and they
weren't willing to put up with well
garbage working in her office that's
that's my opinion and i think that she
that she's trying to distract by
charging the electric car but it shows
the idiocy of washington because she
proposed getting rid of all
gasoline-powered cars by 2035 a few
years ago and she clearly doesn't really
know how to charge electric one well
but joe biden is the boss joe biden is
unpopular it's not kamala's fault is it
well she hasn't helped herself for all
though if you're gonna go down and say
you're gonna fix root causes and then
ghost the guy for six months come on i
mean they did the same thing with the
crime thing remember they're like oh
yeah we're in touch we're sending all
this federal help to these crime-ridden
cities and the sheriffs were like we
haven't heard anything from you guys and
then she scrambles to get something out
and say oh actually
uh you know what we uh we got a bunch of
companies together we're sending down
millions of dollars to central america
she's bragging about how she's bribing
latin american countries you think these
countries are just going to not take all
this money keep it and keep sending the
caravan i think that's what happened to
her plan the reality of central and
south america right it's like every day
it seems like it's her first day on the
job it's so bad geraldo
politico
advice columns yes this is an advice
column how kamal is awesome nothing's
her fault but here's what she can do to
get herself out of this rut and then
they interview six of the most highest
paid political consultants to give her
free advice
i mean i don't remember this happening
with trump you know how
russia's investigation's not trump's
fault what he can do to beat mueller and
win re-election like this is crazy
but you know greg it is a tough job
being seconded by that uh that's true uh
but whose fault is that it's the
democratic party because there's so many
examples of failures caused by just one
variable decision making look at all of
the look at all of her all of who she is
okay she has a lack of charisma she has
a lack of death she has a lack of
seriousness
her primary showing was terrible her
role of a prosecutor was questionable so
those are five variables and if you were
looking at them you would have said hell
no as a vp choice however none of those
variables mattered they looked at one
and that was identity and that was the
one variable she could pass and it was
the only variable that mattered they
needed to pair that identity with an old
white male on his last legs it's like
pairing the right wine with a rubbery
plate of bad chicken so the problem is
whenever you make a decision
yes exactly this is a bad banquet this
any decision based on one variable will
fail 100 of the time
they had all these variables in front of
them that they could have seen that she
was a disaster but they chose one she
was a woman of color did you am i mike
on variables no i i i i've learned that
all from scott adams oh okay am i an old
brown man on his last legs yes
but you know dana i've always said it's
uh her problem is lethargy and a lack of
verve
well here's the thing so when jen sake
was asked that question she
if she had been given permission by the
president and the chief of staff she
could have said it's a great question i
suggest you call the vice president's
office and ask them that's cold and then
but that will force them to do it
because the whole when she went to
guatemala in the first place that was
the photo op
for the root causes to her then she
doesn't do anything else but now they're
trying to fix her problem with photo ops
and crowd sourcing political advice
when it's gonna take some time get some
is it possible
no
okay man
[Laughter]
she wrote and the goodness optimism
and now it's like no it's not